this [ __ ] is fake
diversity all this is fake
none of it's real
it's never been real in my entire life
whether it was the military whether it
was comedy whether it was the art scene
whether it was a grant system whether it
was stand-up whether it's youtube it
doesn't matter
all of this talk is just lip service
they only care about money the
allegations i am levying towards youtube
are extremely serious and i'm taking
this video extremely seriously
youtube
you guys either play favorites
you are racist or it's a mix of the two
here's my proof
i've been doing youtube a long time okay
i never want to be that guy oh it's cuz
i'm black all these issues are happening
because i'm black
there have been certain situations that
i looked at kind of funny i said hmm
it could be because of that but nah i
ain't gonna i'm not trying to press that
i don't want to build that narrative
around my my youtube channel this time
i can no longer let us live this is the
situation august 18th i uploaded the
mortuary assistant a lot of you would
know it got age restricted youtube
didn't tell me why i saw that all these
other youtubers were playing the
mortuary assistant and only my
video seemed to be age restricted and i
looked for like an hour two hours i was
scrolling all different types of
people's video
no one else was age restricted just want
to make something clear
some of you might be looking like what's
the issue with making these videos not
available to kids first off
vast majority of us when we upload we
say we don't want kids watching the
video so we already clicked that
but age restricted is a bit different
i don't know what it is with the
algorithm but if your video gets age
restricted it's probably going to get
demonetized 99.9 percent of the time one
and two it also becomes all of a sudden
less visible to vast majority of people
including your own subscribers whatever
happens if your video gets age
restricted it's pretty much shadow
banned so
just wanted to let y'all know so i
appealed the restriction um hey guys i'm
i'm not sure why mine got age restricted
could you look into this appeal rejected
they doubled down the policy team said
no corey your video is restricted for
good reason we're not going to tell you
why but it's restricted that's our final
decision i said hmm okay i get with my
youtube rep i sent him an email hey
could you look at this this is some
weird stuff going on only my video got
age restricted my youtube rep who isn't
on the policy team he looked at my video
and he said hey it could possibly be
this part at the end where the woman was
battling some depression and i'm just
going to leave it there lest this video
also get age restricted just because i'm
talking about it so i looked at that
part
the first thing i did was try to find
other youtubers who had that part or at
least a part similar now markiplier i
don't know if you'll ever see this but i
just want you to know i have a lot of
respect for you and i didn't mean to
drag you into the middle of this your
channel just happens to be a great
reference point because a you're a
really big youtuber and uh you're not
black
hey listen hey listen my white brother i
needed to use you to make my point and b
you're not black
and i appreciate uh
corey kincher he's like
let me just give you some flowers before
i tell you the truth so i can look at
your channel and then i can look at my
channel or look at anyone else's channel
and make sure that the things in the
games that you play all that they're
enforcing the rules equally to everybody
so i go to markiplier's mortuary
assistant part three and he had the same
situation going on and his video wasn't
age restricted so i send the video to my
youtube rep i say hey um markiplier has
this situation in his video but his is
an age restricted could you send that to
the policy team and see what they say
about that he said wow corey uh that's
some astute detective work let me uh
send this to them and see what they say
what do you think happened after that
i'll give you a second
they came back
and they removed my age restriction they
took it off after they already rejected
my appeal
i sent them the clip of markiplier's
video that has the same thing
and they removed it
now my youtube rep he was excited he was
oh great this is awesome look cory they
took the age restriction off i said why
the reason why he probably mad and why i
would get mad was like oh when i
appealed it you're like doc get back in
your corner when i said but would you
like this white boy through you're like
oh okay actually you know what both
y'all can get through
you know whatever that that that
we don't want to have to go to such
lengths just to get [ __ ] fixed because
then we start looking at you funny you
gonna say you know what it looks like
what does it look like shut up and
dribble
shut up and go back in your corner and
dribble shut up you're getting this
money
yeah we're gonna look back on this one
so let me just fix it that's what it
looks like yeah
i expected them to triple down and give
markiplier an age restriction too
but they looked at mark's video
and they used that to verify my
innocence
so i send my youtube rep a lengthy email
detailing my feelings about the entire
situation actually number one was it
automated or was it a human that age
restricted it in the first place number
two who was the human reviewer that
doubled down and rejected my appeal
number three why did it take
markiplier's clip in order for them to
reverse the decision my youtube rep gets
back with me he wants to hop on a call
we get on the phone um for about 10-15
minutes and i tell him i've been feeling
like this for a long time i've been
feeling like every single time that i
come back to youtube i'm number one
training for a few days and then they
find some arbitrary issue they nitpick
and they try and find something that
they can incriminate me for and try to
push me down you don't believe me what
happened the last time i came back and i
was number one training for like a week
they copyright strike me for a video
that was in 2019 or something like that
so my youtube rep assures me he's going
to continue this dialogue with the
policy team and try to get some answers
to those three questions that i had so
another day another two days go by and
what do you know
they re-age restricted the video they
re-age restricted the video i say no way
did they do that i go to markiplier's
video now and now his video is age
restricted
teddy petty
[Music]
oh you gonna expose me
you always suppose me what the [ __ ] you
did age restricted wow that's crazy
that's crazy and you know what back back
fourth and fourth that's some back and
forth and if you can't imagine how
[ __ ] annoying and look look at the
other day these are first problems but
as somebody who's trying to create
content you don't understand these lines
they make no goddamn sense bro i
remember one time i uploaded a video
and
i took the thumbnail that the cut was
using and i used the exact same
thumbnail on my video my video got
flagged for the thumbnail
the [ __ ] video in question had over
30 million views i said yo there's gotta
be a mistake i went on my cell phone let
me let me log into this because i got
adblock on computer right pc master race
i think i'm gonna watch some ad please
watch ads you know i want some ads are
you stupid me
but on my cell phone you know let me
support i go on this video
heads to the wazoo state farm out my
butthole plain i'm cool with it but
you're not gonna get monetized
our video our video limited ads age
restricted
for the thumbnail it's the exact same
[ __ ] thumbnail
and
my experience on youtube is when it
comes to demonetization age restriction
you get zero to little like tonight
they don't explain anything they don't
explain they used to do a thing where
they would tell you the reason now they
don't even do that they just said we've
confirmed that it's not suitable for all
advertisers so you sitting there like
guessing like yo what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this video you start censoring
words it's not like i'm yelling slurs or
anything it's not even that they just
get weird about stuff you can't even
understand
and so when you guys see us avoiding
certain words it's because if we don't
it's not even just about the money it's
not even just about that
if we don't the video doesn't get seen
it's not even the money it's just you
seeing the video a lot of a lot of you
guys a lot of you guys have you noticed
it was a trend a couple of years back
that people always all these youtubers
were always saying please make sure that
you click on the bell make sure that you
click on the bell
bells are clicked
people don't get the notification have
you noticed that people nowadays when
you watch youtuber they say please
subscribe but the bell thing they're
like that bell don't work
that bell stopped ringing a long time
ago a lot of you are subscribed and
telling me i don't receive any
notifications you have to come back
every day to see if that blue dot is on
the face yeah that's what you got to do
it's crazy yeah there's been some things
a bit whoa nicki
nicky whoa
yeah it's it's we need to talk about
some things because some things ain't
right and
youtube does this like corny thing or
they have like uh black voices
and i've sent because my my youtube rep
has sent me the link oh you know apply
for black voices and stat
i've never applied for it it's basically
a grant that you get a certain amount of
money help you produce videos et cetera
et cetera i've sent it to other creators
who are a little bit smart who don't
have a partner i'm like you guys might
want to jump on this it'll help you guys
get some cash and stuff
the reason why
is i know one i probably won't get
accepted okay and two
youtube wants minorities but they don't
want you
to be outside of what their box is you
get what i'm trying to say they want to
like
include black folks in a lot of ways but
if you talk a certain way you use
certain words they start to look at you
funny i have times where youtube is
talking about oh we want to make sure
we're supporting minorities through
these difficult times and blah blah blah
every video that we ever did on any
police interaction
crazy footage or not and most of the
time we didn't even put any crazy
footage in age restricted demonetized
couldn't be viewed so even the stuff
that we do want to talk about that
affects your community youtube like goes
out of their way to make sure that [ __ ]
not possible meanwhile i got a bunch of
white political commentators who can say
anything about any topic and they should
always pass
me on the outside looking in
this is what i think
it's not my platform
i'ma take from this what i can get
i'm not gonna beg
i'm not gonna piss him on i'm not gonna
cry
it is what it is it is
i've seen enough of this [ __ ] my whole
[ __ ] entire life let me get mine and
keep it pushing demanding people who
have way more power way more money than
me to change for me waste a [ __ ]
time do lip service
but the only thing that these
[ __ ] care about
is dineros
so you ask me what i think honestly
i get you corey i understand you can
demand change
they'll give you the lip service they'll
do the little spiel
but at the end of the day
it's about that money you want to know
what the difference is between you and a
lot of other creators is the truth
you're just not as brand safe
you feel me
we don't gotta say why we understand
you're just not as brand safe
they're gonna do two things
companies like this make two things
money
look good
thinking about say apologies
look good
all right tutor apologies
you look good yeah we know what it is
we promise we'll change
look good that's it it's money
and look good we're committed to making
a difference in minority communities if
we look good
that's what it is
that's really what it is so you have to
what's in it for why would they do that
to you maybe it's like a
you can say that it's a thing where i
don't have a lot of lit self-esteem or i
i've been broken by the system where i
know you know my places where i know
like i'm not that worth it for them but
it's what it is
it's not i still still keep on making
their money
and he's still looking good i'm out of
the equation go ahead it's not
we don't we're like dissing it we
understand what the system is built for
yes right so once you sign up to the
system don't get in and be like yo what
the [ __ ] is this because even though the
brochure is a little bit misleading
you've lived long enough as a black man
to understand what these systems are you
get what i'm trying to say just fine
listen i've worked in the entertainment
industry before i ever did this [ __ ]
it's no different no it's the same game
so
get what you can out of it but always
understand this is like a negotiation
thing too right i understood this early
on when i began negotiating contracts
for comedy gigs for festivals for brand
deals
you have to understand who has the power
because at the end of the day they
dictate the terms and what they do with
the terms is they use it in their best
interest so when i had [ __ ] when i was
going to the negotiating table with
comedy festivals they were giving me
crumbs
why because they didn't have to do more
they might have paid me some lip service
words are cheap put the money no
once i got the following it's a
different thing because the influence is
there and now they need my money but
youtube is so big they can afford to
lose you you get what i'm saying why
because that advertisers got so much
more money to be given they know what it
is so
understand that relationship and move
accordingly and always in your best
interest when it comes to business be
very short about your [ __ ]
in all my years have never seen a video
get age restricted d age restricted and
then age restricted again have any of
you ever seen that happen before they
saw that i saw that there was some
unfair stuff going on so then they tried
to appease me by d age restricting the
video look good
why is my channel so much more heavily
scrutinized than my peers my peers and
when i say peers i mean people around my
level around my view count just to keep
it simple why is my channel so much more
thoroughly scrutinized especially so
when i've been number one training
multiple days in a row which i've done
multiple times and every single time i
start to get an uptick in traction and
uptake and activity
here comes youtube coming through hey um
uh uh let's get it for that video from
2019. yeah you see this cory no this is
bad it wasn't bad the nine months that i
was off the platform it was only bad
when i got back and i was number one
trending every other youtuber has
uploaded the mortuary assistant and now
they're about to start putting in some
age restrictions because i called them
out on some unfair behavior now i
realize that when you call someone this
that's a very very serious accusation
and for that matter how do you expressly
prove that someone is erased i mean
unless they're spamming the n-word in
the chat how how do you really know
corey let me ask how do you feel about
the kick
well i'd like to know what abb and
preach think if the kkk had a had a
youtube channel you mean like the kkk it
sounds like something i said like a day
ago i'm saying you want to know the
truth and this is something that black
people echo
you know what black people are really
tired of
we're tired of
innuendo when it comes to racism
we're tired of like the subversive stuff
you know the stuff where people act i'm
just like you know it's like i feel you
less than 24 hours i feel you i get it
everyone know what the answer is what's
the answer you can't you wanna know why
cause they got the code
cause if you do they gonna make you feel
crazy and say oh you're being
insensitive but
we generally know we just can't say it
because everything is all
most of the time when i'm with black
people everything is all [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's like [ __ ] boys
but racism addiction it's hard to detect
the intentions these
situations always coincide with an
uptick of growth and it always just
comes off like we can't let this black
guy get too high up
i mean if i'm wrong i'm wrong
i'm telling you that's how it comes off
i don't see any other youtuber that gets
number one trending many times and then
all of a sudden they're getting age
restricted and they're getting copyright
strikes and all of that if i'm wrong i'm
wrong point him out i want to see him
i'll retract this entire video i like
the fact that you admit that you might
be wrong yeah you you honestly
believe that you might be wrong and
that's why i believe that's what you
don't have the proof at the end of the
day but they don't look good
they don't look good
that's true
i mean
a lot of the reason i keep playing this
video shout out to corey um that's a new
word like i just said man that's a new
word you just invented a new word no
that word was amazing what is
that man
that word
all right listen and this is just advice
for y'all emma young up and coming
trying to get your food in the doing
business transactions it does you very
little to no good okay
to
get mad about this [ __ ]
all right because the powers have me
they only care about they money so get
your money however you can be mindful be
aware see what's popping okay but just
focus on getting your wealth together so
that when you come to the negotiating
table there's not an imbalance of power
because that's the only thing that
matters to these people that's it all
this talk about well you guys have a
commitment to this [ __ ] is fake
diversity all this is fake
none of it's real
it's never been real in my entire life
whether it was the military whether it
was comedy whether it was the art scene
whether it was the grant system whether
it was stand-up whether it's youtube it
doesn't matter
all of this talk is just lip service and
they only care
about money that's it the reason that
they doing this cory is not even because
you're black you want to know what it is
it's because of what you represent as a
black person the two things are
different they don't hate whatever it is
that you are it's not that
they hate what you represent though is
they understand what it means in a
greater system
when it comes to advertising when it
comes to this or that they understand
that's it so listen you can take it
personal you're entitled to feel however
you want to feel listen i'm not going to
tell nobody how to process it and if
ever
it actually changes after you did all
that it's only because they were able to
monetize that change that's right and
you're a part of that that's it
y'all never notice youtube don't really
change the only time youtube changes
after a big scandal
you guys never notice that
adpocalypse happened after what
all these diversity movements happen
after what it's reactive
but it's not reactive because they got a
heart because they got a conscious think
of what it's reacting you believe that
really it's reactive because they got a
wallet
i say this because i know what it was
like to try to fight the system it's so
emotionally taxing it's so [ __ ]
tiring and then afterwards you got no
energy and no desire to want to do the
creative [ __ ] that you wanted to do
before
so i'm just telling you this is [ __ ]
but you gotta endure it and be smart
about your [ __ ] because you only got so
much energy inside you you only got some
there's a man
listen man
hey man fighting that fight is tiring i
got a family to take care of i got my
mental health to take care of trying to
change people who got more power than
you no no not people
businesses
it's a business it's a losing fight get
your money get your bread you get me all
right get your [ __ ] together
move smart
that's all we can really do oh no me no
we're not get we don't get frustrated
from the out of town
it gets you're right you're you're right
to be frustrated you are right to be
frustrated i just want to put it out
there we're not saying shut the [ __ ] no
no that's not worth saying do you you
did that we did it gets
frustrated super frustrating let me tell
you you guys remember that video that
preach did recently the one where he was
talking about his experience
uh with who was the one who was really
harassing him when he was a young man
now i got business i re-edited that
video
seven times
seven times because every time he would
get age restricted and i was confused by
the time i was done i don't [ __ ]
butchered the [ __ ] so [ __ ] bad i
couldn't even recognize the video
you would have thought preach turned
mute some points because i had to remove
that
that
i had to cut out some sections
because i'm like i don't know what's
wrong with this one but it seems to be
this i had to like upload four minutes
and then four minutes and then four
minutes just to find out where the
[ __ ] problem was so trust me
i get it
but we gotta make our bread
we gotta do what we gotta do
so just be mindful